i keep telling everybody every time we
talk about investing the key is
diversifications i feel good about the
expense but i also feel good from an
investment strategy that it's not just
frivolous and stupid that i needed to
get my money back out of it i could
that's the whole idea
you want to find a place in life
regardless how much money you make well
basically
you enjoy what you do
[Music]
miami you know when we do picnics in
miami we don't go to the park
we get on a boat and we cruise around
bring all the goodies with us
so i want to spend a little time with
you today doing what i love to do
hanging out on the boat with my friends
and family it's great
but really what i want to talk about is
what i call millionaire life hacks
you know there are certain things you
can do to really be productive
to really make your life better and
easier and i don't just mean money it's
not just about money
it's lifestyle it's health it's how you
look it's how you feel that's what we're
going to spend some time on today
and why not do it on a spectacular boat
with the classic stone crab
oh yeah baby
[Music]
so the party's in full swing you can
hear it out there but i wanted to take a
break and talk a little bit
about millionaire hacks okay yeah we're
on the boat we're having a big picnic i
think that's great
and before things get too crazy i
thought i want to talk about my sponsor
this week
tiege hanley now one of the things you
got to think about
and i just brought out the dome of
desire is
when you go out on a boat you're outside
and generally speaking
when you're really spending time walking
around
exercising you've got to think about
skin care
because one of the things you have to do
is you want to look good as long as you
can look good for
and you don't want your skin to get
burned and leathery and it ages you
why do that you know yeah i'm vain i get
it so i use tiege hanley these guys
subscription service fantastic
and any of my subscribers are going to
get a free toiletry bag for these
but they send you everything you need
because i don't like to read all the
instructions
but basically washes you get a fantastic
thing for a scrub taking
you know i use a lot of makeup and
television this scrub is great but the
one i use every day
is this one this am this is a
moisturizer
with basically 20 spf so for sun
blocking right
so just a little squirt of it right on
the dome
that's how you protect the dome of
desire and then
on my face because i really don't want
to get burned and also
your neck area anyways it's a great deal
check it out and that's like millionaire
hack number one
look good feel good you want to be
healthy
in your older age you got to start at
your younger age take care of yourself
i'm wearing an aura ring now this is i'm
not a rep roar i don't own the stock
they're not paying me for anything i'm
using it to monitor my slate
a couple of things i've learned if you
eat too late
and you drink too late you screw up your
sleep and you don't get that really
valuable rem sleep
and you want that rem sleep to stay
sharp and feel good the next day so
really what you want to do is sleep an
average
minimum of seven hours and 11 minutes
there's a lot of studies i've been
reading this stuff
and you want to go to bed at least three
and a half hours after you took your
last drink
now that's hard to do and i totally get
that
but i've been modifying my behavior by
shifting my dinner up an hour
so i'm drinking wine at 7 30 8 30
and then i stop and believe me i'm like
gnawing at my hand i'm so unhappy about
that
because i love the wine business i'm in
the wine business but i have to stop
three and a half hours before i go to
sleep
and the productivity or sleep goes
through the roof also
another little call it a body hack
millionaire body hack i know a lot of
people doing this
fasting so if you finish your dinner at
8 30
okay you basically don't want to eat
again if you can do it
for 14 hours minimum
12 hours but you want if you can kind of
wean yourself to 14 hours
a you lose more weight b you feel
terrific
but this your body really wants that
break in processing food in your stomach
just a body hack thing
you will love it so basically finish
eating at let's say
nine o'clock you do not want to eat
again until nine in the morning but
better
eat at 11 30 in the morning or better
even still i'm not
telling you what to do if your doctor
has different advice but don't eat
breakfast
eat at lunch that's what i'm kind of
getting into these days
and you feel so much better and you know
everybody's got their own ideas but
that's another hack i want to talk about
now let's talk about investing
investing is tricky because we may have
inflation coming into the market
what matters is worrying about inflation
so that interest rates on 10-year bonds
for example go up that can hurt stocks
but only if it goes over three percent
which it doesn't look like it's going to
happen but i keep telling everybody
every time we talk about investing
the key is diversification so number one
no more than five percent in any one
stock at any one time of your portfolio
no more than 20 percent of any sector
like
energy or like technology or consumer
goods
whatever you know you don't want more
than 20 you follow those two rules
you get diversification and it's very
good for you when markets go up and down
but you never get wiped out because you
own 80 of one stock or something like
that that's a bad idea
all right last when you buy stuff okay
buy less stuff but buy good stuff
i've talked about this in ad nauseam now
i'm wearing a watch this is kind of a
crazy watch
it's a little blinged out see that
blinged out stuff going on there
that's because it's miami and this is a
diamond encrusted rolex daytona now how
corny is that
would i wear this somewhere else no
probably not in miami
it's perfect the kind of stuff they like
here it's kind of you know
flamboyant to say the least but in far
as i'm concerned
yes it's an expensive watch but it it's
an investment
it's appreciated value it's up about 30
from where i bought it and so i feel
good about the expense but i also feel
good from an investment strategy that
it's not just
frivolous and stupid that i needed to
get my money back out of it i could
that's the whole idea
so investing really matters millionaire
money hack is basically making sure you
don't blow your money
you can spend it on things but what you
really want are things that appreciate
value
so you don't need another pair of jeans
because you don't need them because
you've got five of them already well
then do the right thing
invest in things that appreciate
overvalue they don't have to be over
time i mean
they don't have to be just stocks
guitars pans watches
wine collections they appreciate i know
the story about wine
you drink your whole stash how are you
going to get a return on it you don't
have to
i have lots of friends that trade their
wines futures trade their their high-end
ones
and they profit from it because one
becomes more valuable over time
at least french mine does so these are
just some ideas
and lastly you know the most important
hack in life is you gotta have fun
you gotta have fun like you really don't
want to stress yourself out i work
every day okay but i do it because i
want to
and i pursue the things that are of
interest to me
deals i want to do that mean something
to me and the people that work with me
and
that way it doesn't seem like work to me
i want to get up in the morning and work
on it
you want to find a place in life
regardless of how much money you make
well basically
you enjoy what you do that's number one
for me
you only have so many years you want to
enjoy the stuff you do that's the key to
success i keep saying this all the time
another sip of lemonade anybody can do
these things and that's what i like
about it
when you start a business and a third of
you will
what a timeline on what it's going to
take to be profitable
my rule is 36 months that's three years
if you're not
profitable after three years
take the whole thing up behind the barn
and shoot it complete waste your time
you only have so many years to get a
deal done
you can fail a couple of times i
certainly did but you need one to work
and that sets you free it's not about
the greed of money what i'm doing right
now is because i
want to the only reason i can do this
picnic on a boat today and enjoy our
time together is
entrepreneurship hard to do this when
you're working nine to five for somebody
else
it's not a bad thing it's just that if
you really want to set yourself free
you got to spend a period of your life
really working hard
it's not a great balanced lifestyle or
anything but
if you're successful you do this
and this is worth doing and i wish the
success on all of you
if you like that video wait you see my
next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe
who showed you the way was it one mentor
that pointed left or right and you found
your way
i doubt it no the life of hard knocks
pushed me all over the place
absolutely so what he's looking to is
someone else for an answer
bad idea all your answers have to do
with yourself